robert is in orlando hey robert welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey how are you guys doing today better
than i deserve man how can we help
so i will be starting law school next
fall i'm 23 years old and my only debt
is a 17 000
car loan that i might sell depending on
where i moved to
uh currently i make 32 000 a year and
have about 15 000 in safe stock
hopefully that'll be able to grow to
about 20 before i start
i do have an emergency fund as well as a
roth that i contribute to every month
my question is should i use that 15 to
20 000 to pay for rent
and living expenses while i'm in law
school or just take out enough student
loans to be able to pay for
those living expenses and just focus on
school robert did you really just call
the dave ramsey show
to ask dave if you should take out a
student loan
are you new are you new to this robert
are you brand new
as a matter of fact i am okay all right
well let me keep him calm then you just
be nice to me no crazy i'm going to
scare them i'm the nice one robert
here's the thing buddy i love the fact
that you've got a career track
i even love that you know the direction
you want to go
uh but here's what i want you to avoid
we have a 1.7
trillion dollar epidemic going on uh
excuse me billion dollar epidemic drone
uh it's going to get to that pretty soon
uh trillion
with student loans it's a situation and
so what i don't want you to do i want
you to chase your dreams but i don't
want you to grab student loans
i really and truly don't uh you've got
an opportunity to look at this and start
to think
you can go tonight i've got friends that
have done this my friend where you're
enrolling and going to law school at
night while you're working
and it might take a little bit longer
but for you to come out of that without
student loans would be a game changer
the um the stories that we've heard
robert over the last 20 years
25 years of doing coaching with people
financially that
took out a law school loan uh they're
200 000
in debt and all on the premise that this
was all going to work the way it was
supposed to work and life
never works exactly the way it's
supposed to work and so they end up not
passing the bar
and let me tell you what your law degree
is worth then
economically speaking not so much um
or so they end up deciding they want to
be more of a public servant and they
want to work for the government
as a lawyer which means you get paid
squat but you've got
big old student loans that you've got
based on the fact you're going to be a
rich lawyer someday
and so it doesn't turn out the way
people think it's going to turn out
always there's all kinds of different
things that happen it takes longer to
get the law
career started and get the income to go
with it all those kinds of things so it
you put yourself in a
dramatic disadvantage when you take on
these student loans
so that's why we're always trying to
talk people out of it